let's talk more about that story now
with the Deputy Foreign Minister of
Ukraine Elena zurka who joins us here in
studio good morning to you mr. Coe thank
you very much for being with us this
morning we saw there a list of issues to
discuss but first let's talk about
domestic policy yesterday Parliament
voted to dismiss the public prosecutor
for the third time since 2014 for not
being tough enough on corruption how big
of an issue is corruption it's more the
lack of trust to the prosecutor office
as such because we inherited this office
since the orange since their last
revolution in the current condition and
of course this is a necessity to change
a perception a perception of the
prosecutors and their role in the
society because we used to have such an
old Soviet style prosecutor office and
we definitely need to change this and
this is quite a crucial change because
actually it will mean the change of
approaches in each and every dimension
of the prosecution in Ukraine and
Ukrainians they don't believe to such a
procedure now okay so there's a lack of
trust in that office also it seems in
the political system in general and
let's talk about the current political
crisis why can't these various parties
at play create a stable coalition
because most of them have different aims
and goals we do understand that some
kind of parallel elections may appear
because of lack of trust in the
government in the society because all
these changes we are going through now
they're painful all increase of tariffs
a decrease of salaries and so on this
creates a situation when people are not
satisfied with the current situation and
of course it has some implication the
political situation overall one reason
they're not satisfied is the economy of
course at risk if there's no stable
coalition is a 1.7
billion dollar loan from the IMF do you
think we could see the economy of
collapse because there's no stable
government I still believe that they
will manage to agree among each other
because definitely it's not only about
the political forces it's about the
country and that will join them in a
common understanding of the necessity to
create such a government which will be
quite stable with the view to go through
all these painful challenges I want to
bring up that term lack of trust that
you mentioned already that's something
that some Ukrainians have expressed
towards president poroshenko after he's
failed to follow through on some of the
reform promises for example tackling
corruption do you think that faith in
his government is still there I may say
that of course after the Revolution
citizens expected much more and faster
reforms and more results should be
delivered but you see the changes in
general in the society and the
approaches they're very slow and of
course it's also a lack of understanding
of the necessary changes we do want to
live in a new way
but we don't want to change ourselves
and to behave in another Munir because
corruption is everywhere and it's up to
people to change their own behavior and
not to give bribes we saw the Prime
Minister Arseniy Yatsenyuk in that
report he and president poroshenko do
not see eye to eye on various issues
what is the problem there I can't say
that they don't see eye to eye each
other they have very permanent meetings
and they talk a lot about a lot of
things but definitely this is not only
the personal factor this is the factor
of the perception among political
parties the parties itself they don't
believe to each other because of
breaking promises in the past I want to
move now of course to the situation in
the east of the country we have to talk
about that as well there have been
various ceasefire violation
and there are growing concerns on the
side of negotiators France and Germany
that the Minsk deal will not actually
lead to anything why do you think this
deal has failed to take shape I can't
say that it failed we still believe that
some kind of progress is possible and we
definitely see that the situation in the
East is much calmer than it used to be a
year ago of course it's not a full
ceasefire but it's more secure than it's
used to be and this is the progress that
we achieved of course we have not
achieved the full progress in the
humanitarian aspects and we did not
manage to change all hostages and this
is one of the crucial issues because for
instance Nadia Savchenko is one of the
hostages and political hostages which is
now in Russia and we can solve this
issue without understanding how to move
further and with all these processes
with Minsk you see we can't just close
our eyes on the existing problems in the
East because we still don't have full
access of SMM OSCE to the territories we
can't secure our people on the contact
line and we still can't understand how
to deal with the elections because for
the free elections you will need access
at least of the media to that territory
is it possible but doesn't the
government is not part of the men's ik
agreement the terms that an election law
does need to be passed for the Donbass
region
know that it's not actually the point
the point is what will be in that law
what kind of constellation we will face
in this law whether it will be fair
whether this internally displaced people
will have access to this elections
because these are main and crucial
blocking points in this discussion right
you mentioned nadia savchenko i do want
to ask her about her how much strain is
the controversy over her imprisonment
putting on ukraine's role at the
relations with russia this is just one
of the points or which showed us all the
situation with the relations because she
is a hostage and she is quite a picture
of such relations between Russia and
Ukraine what are you demanding from the
Russian side there of course we are
demanding to get your back and that's
our full and constant demand now I want
to ask you about of course you're here
in Germany about Ukraine's relations
with the EU what is your message to
Western leaders many of them welcomed
the Ukrainian new Ukrainian government
but the coup they're just made about the
reports of corruption and mismanagement
what do you have to say to that that
despite all challenges we're still
moving on the way on the path of our
reforms and we actually delivered a lot
during last period and that was actually
in the report of the European Commission
at the end of the year that we made a
significant progress for instance in the
combating corruption and creation of the
new institutions of course we need some
time to make this institution workable
and to deliver some results of their
work however I still believes that we
are on the right way the EU has backed
visa-free access for Ukraine do you
still see that happening yeah I hope
that we will have this axis this year
where do you see your country with a
current political crisis an economic
crisis where do you see your country in
five years time I suppose that all these
reforms will bring our country closer to
Europe and that we will bring Europe to
our country that we will change the
perception of our citizens and they will
be responsible for their future and will
the conflict in the east of the country
be ended I hope so because this is quite
an artificial conflict and I hope that
we will manage to cope with this
conflict because this is not a matter
the conflict is such this is an issue of
aggression and if we will manage to
block this aggression we will manage to
find a solution inside this society
all right a lot of tasks ahead for your
government deputy foreign minister
Elena's Arkell thank you so much for
joining us this morning in studio thank
you